es wurde lange befürchtet und jetzt
bestätigt bahnbrechende Erkenntnisse und
Erfindungen in der Wissenschaft werden
immer seltener und das in allen
Bereichen liegt es in der Natur der
Sache fördern wir die falschen Studien
oder ist der Fortschritt jetzt einfach
vorbei wir haben uns die Studie
angeschaut die das herausgefunden hat
und mit einer Vertreterin der Deutschen
Forschungsgemeinschaft gesprochen einem
der größten Geldgeber für Wissenschaft
in Deutschland also was ist da los ist
die Wissenschaft am Ende
im Januar erschien eine Studie in nature
für die die Forschenden eine nie da
gewesene Anzahl an Veröffentlichungen
auf ihre disruptivität überprüft haben
die Idee disruptive Fachartikel
revolutionieren das Denken über mehrere
Fachgebiete hinweg und werden dann auch
von Forscherinnen und Forschern zitiert
die aus anderen Fachbereichen kommen das
Gegenteil davon sind konsolidierende
Fachartikel die die bestehende Forschung
bestätigen und ergänzen das interessiert
dann nur die Forschenden im selben
Fachgebiet die Studie schaut sich
deshalb an wann welche Artikel von wem
zitiert wurden und das Ergebnis ist er
nüchtern seit den 1950ern ist ihr Maß
für disruptivität in wissenschaftlichen
Fachartikeln um über 90% gesunken das
hier ist uns verloren gegangen das heißt
krasse Erkenntnisse die aus ihrem
eigenen kleinen Spezialbereich
ausbrechen und so einen Großteil der
Wissenschaft beeinflussen werden immer
selten er
die Ergebnisse haben sie mit weiteren
Methoden bestätigt für die teils schaut
dazu gerne mal in die Quellen das
Original paper ist frei zugänglich okay
das Ergebnis ist nicht gut das findet
auch Dr Annette Schmidtmann Leiterin der
Abteilung für fachliche Angelegenheiten
der Forschungsförderung bei der
Deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft ich
denke wir brauchen aufgrund der gerade
in der jetzigen Zeit auch aufgrund der
vielen Probleme die wir in der Welt
haben brauchen wir eigentlich ständig
neue Forschungsergebnisse und mit diesen
Problemen umzugehen also warum bleiben
die großen Sprünge aus die Antwort ist
wie immer kompliziert man sollte meinen
je mehr wissen es gibt desto mehr neue
Erkenntnisse bekommt man auch oder wie
es Isaac Newton ausgedrückt hat wenn ich
weiter sehen konnte dann weil ich auf
dem Schultern von riesenstand diese
Riesen waren nie so groß wie heute die
Wissenschaft wächst seit vielen
Jahrzehnten weltweit exponentiell an
fehlendem Wissen und fehlenden Personal
kann es also noch nicht liegen
vielleicht wird es schlicht immer
schwieriger revolutionäre Erkenntnisse
zu gewinnen im englischen spricht man
hier von low hanging fruits also wenn
das Wissen der Welt wie Früchte an einem
Baum hängt dann kommt man an die Früchte
an den unteren Ästen am einfachsten
sobald die aber gepflückt sind muss man
den Baum immer höher klettern und das
wird dann immer schwieriger die low
hanging fruits haben wir also vielleicht
in den letzten Jahrhunderten schon
gepflückt Kopernikus Galileo und ihre
altgriechischen Vordenker stellten
unsere Vorstellung vom Kosmos ganz ohne
Teleskope und Computer auf den Kopf
heute vernetzen hunderte von
Forscherinnen und Forschern riesige
Radioteleskope rund um den Erdball und
werden die Daten mit Supercomputern aus
um dann doch nur wieder die
Relativitätstheorie zu bestätigen Note
Fotos von Schwarzen Löchern sind hammer
und super informativ aber ihre Existenz
ist eben eigentlich auch keine
Überraschung mehr und dann kommt noch
dazu Wissenschaft ist heute einfach
wahnsinnig
interessiert vielleicht stoßen wir
Menschen inzwischen einfach an unsere
Kapazitäten
bahnbrechende Ideen entstehen oft
nämlich durch das Kombinieren von Wissen
aus unterschiedlichen Bereichen in der
Renaissance war das einfach da konnten
universal Gelehrte sich noch alles
verfügbare Wissen zu einem Problem
aneignen heute ist jeder einzelne
Forscher und jeder einzelne Forscherin
voll damit beschäftigt auf dem neuesten
Stand des eigenen Spezialgebietes zu
bleiben das würde auch erklären warum
die Studie herausfand dass sie immer
weniger über den Tellerrand schauen
genau wie wir uns heute mit der Zukunft
der Wissenschaft auseinandersetzen
sollte sich jeder von uns auch mit
seiner persönlichen Zukunft
auseinandersetzen insbesondere mit
Hinblick auf die Altersvorsorge ja ja
ich weiß das Thema ist nicht besonders
sexy aber es ist extrem wichtig klagt
kennt ihr vielleicht schon die App kann
euch dabei helfen den Überblick über
eure Altersvorsorge zu behalten und sie
zu optimieren gerade wenn man noch am
Anfang des Berufslebens steht kann es
aufgrund der langen Ansparphase mega
sinnvoll sein sich zusätzlich
gesetzlichen Rente auch über eine
private Rente Gedanken zu machen und
hier kann es bestimmt nicht schaden sich
Clark mal anzuschauen in der App könnt
ihr eure zukünftige Altersvorsorge ganz
einfach über das rentencockpit checken
lassen um herauszufinden welche
Altersvorsorge für euch sinnvoll ist es
gibt auch die Möglichkeit euch am selben
Tag noch dazu in einem Gespräch beraten
zu lassen wenn ihr euch verklagt
entscheidet denkt dran die unterschreibt
damit ein maklermandat nur so kann die
App für euch Versicherungen abschließen
wenn ihr euch eine ausgesucht habt wenn
ihr bereits bestehende Versicherungen
habt und diese mit Clark teilt dann
erhaltet ihr einen Gutschein von bis zu
45 € die dir bei vielen verschiedenen
Marken einlösen können so Clark App
kommt ihr über den QR Code hier oder
über den Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung und wenn ihr den nutzt
oder den Code Watson verwendet dann
unterstützt sie damit auch noch wie
immer uns und unsere Videos vielen Dank
dafür
dass die großen Sprünge in Forschung und
Entwicklung ausbleiben könnte also
einfach in der Natur der Sache liegen
einfach weil Wissenschaft immer
schwieriger und irgendwann dann eben zu
schwierig wird ist es das was wir
beobachten wird es für uns Menschen so
komplex neue Durchbrüche zu erzielen
dass die Wissenschaft einfach zum
Stillstand kommt bevor wir jetzt eine
existenzielle Krise bekommen vielleicht
liegt es ja gar nicht an der Natur des
Wissens vielleicht liegt es daran wie
wir Wissenschaft betreiben wie die
Arbeitsbedingungen in der Wissenschaft
kreativer und produktiver Arbeit im Weg
stehen können darüber haben wir schon in
einem anderen Video gesprochen dass ihr
hier gerne anschauen könnt jetzt wollen
wir wissen ob das Ausbleiben großer
innovationsprünge an der Förderung liegt
darüber haben wir mit Frau Dr
Schmidtmann von der DFG gesprochen wird
nur noch kleinschrittige Mainstream
Forschung gefördert statt mutiger und
innovativer Forschung
aber erstmal wer ist denn eigentlich die
Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft die DFG
ist der größte Anbieter von Drittmitteln
Drittmittel sind eine Art Zuschuss für
laufende Forschungsprojekte also
zunächst forschmann mit dem Geld von der
Uni an seinem Interessengebiet und wenn
man etwas Großem auf der Spur ist dann
kann man für eine befristete Dauer
zusätzliche Mittel bei der DFG
beantragen die Aufgabe der DFD ist ganz
kurz gesagt die Förderung der besten
Forschung nice aber was heißt das die
DFG fördert gut ausgearbeitete
Forschungsprojekte von Forschenden die
die notwendigen Kompetenzen mitbringen
und zwar unabhängig vom Thema das heißt
wir haben schon einmal zwei Stellen in
der Förderung von Wissenschaft wo die
Themenwahl ganz den Forschenden
überlassen wird die Uni und die DFG auch
an einigen Forschungsinstituten haben
die Forscher komplett freie Themenwahl
z.B an Max planck-instituten innovative
Forschung wird hier also erstmal nicht
zurückgehalten
parallel dazu gibt es aber auch andere
Strategien zum Beispiel vom zweitgrößten
Anbieter von Drittmitteln dem
Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung wenn der Bund beschließt auf
diesen Gebiet brauchen wir mehr
Forschung dann wird gezielt gefördert
zum Beispiel haben sie die Einrichtung
von 100 Professuren finanziert die nur
an künstlicher Intelligenz arbeiten
dürfen aber die DFG soll vor allem
Neugier getriebene Grundlagenforschung
fördern damit immer genug Wissen
bereitsteht um zukünftige Krisen zu
bewältigen wir wissen nicht was morgen
passiert und was übermorgen passiert
schon gar nicht und wir müssen einfach
in allen Bereichen der Forschung
präpariert sein möglichst viele Ideen
möglichst verschiedene Ansätze
verschiedene Methoden einfach
auszuprobieren sie weiterzuentwickeln um
sie dann Bedarfsfall sozusagen neu zu
kombinieren und sofort für die
Fragestellung einsetzen zu können also
eigentlich ist das ein wappnet für die
Zukunft was wir hier machen okay cool
der Großteil der öffentlichen Förderung
schränkt die Forscherinnen und Forscher
also nicht grundsätzlich ein man kann
den Mainstream verlassen wenn man möchte
Unis und Max-Planck-Institute Stellen
sogar Geld zur Verfügung ohne dass
einzelne Projekte geprüft werden das
sieht allerdings bei der DFG anders aus
sie gehen mit dem öffentlichen Geld
vorsichtiger um das heißt Projekte die
den Mainstream verlassen also
tendenziell eher riskant sind haben
schlechtere Karten wir tun uns als
Drittmittel Förderer schwer Ideen zu
bewerten für die ist noch keinerlei
proof auf Konzept gibt oder wo die
Gutachter sagen das halten sich für
kritisch das zu fördern weil es ist
nicht sicher ob das Erfolg bringt das
kann man den bestimmten Programmen tun
das machen wir auch aber wenn wir ein
Übermaßen Projekten fördern würden bei
denen kein Ergebnis rauskommt da würde
sich der Steuerzahler und die Geldgeber
mit Rechtsfragen Liebe DFB was macht ihr
da man kann also nicht einfach schreiben
ich brauche Geld und dann bekommt man
das auch so wie Otto Warburg 1931 kein
Scherz der Antrag hat noch nicht mal
einen satzschlusszeichen und hat
trotzdem funktioniert bei mir wäre das
ja schon an meiner Grundschullehrerin
gescheitert hat stattdessen muss man
eine Gutachtergruppe überzeugen dass das
Forschungsprojekt mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit einen Erkenntnisgewinn
bringen würde dafür braucht man viel
versprechen der erste Ergebnisse und man
muss sich bereits durch gute Arbeiten
hervorgetan haben die in Prestige
trächtigen Journals veröffentlicht
wurden zum publikationsdruck in der
Wissenschaft könnte ich übrigens auch
dieses Video hier anschauen
auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich gut
dass man mit Steuergeldern
verantwortungsvoll umgeht und das auf
jeden Fall richtig so auf der anderen
Seite wenn eine ganze Gruppe von Leuten
ein Projekt begutachtet und jeder seine
Bedenken einfließen lässt werden
wirklich mutiger und innovative Projekte
dann nicht er aussortiert das ist
sicherlich so dazu gibt es ja auch
wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen die das
bestätigen und das kann man sich auch
als Laie gut vorstellen weil eine Gruppe
von zehn Wissenschaftlern da sitzt und
hat 100 Anträge zur Bewertung vorliegen
kann aber nur 30 davon fördern hat mehr
Geld ist nicht da dann muss diese Worte
sich irgendwie einigen im Ergebnis wird
bei der DFG also doch konservativer
gefördert als vielleicht gewünscht aber
Dr Schmidtmann ist überzeugt dass die
Förderung mutige Ideen auch bei der DFB
nicht völlig unter den Tisch fällt da
braucht man im Grunde eine Person in der
gesagt der Gruppe die sagt und ich
glaube daran und ich finde da hat sie
was gefunden und das müssen wir machen
und es lohnt auf jeden Fall dieses
Projekt zu fahren und wenn nichts
herauskommt sind wir auch schlauer so
ein Advokaten braucht man dann und ich
glaube dass wir eigentlich für unsere
Fachkollegen bei der DFG sagen können
wenn ein solches Projekt da ist wohin wo
jemand spürt da ist was dran dann gibt
es diesen einen Advokaten dann gibt es
diese advokantin auch die Sachen und das
müssen wir jetzt mal riskieren Leute
reißt euch zusammen das machen wir jetzt
das fördern wir also diesen Spirit
behaupte ich jetzt mal den gibt es in
unseren gutachtergruppen okay die
Förderung innovativer und mutiger
Forschungsprojekte ist also
grundsätzlich möglich vor allem wenn die
Mittel von der Uni oder dem
Forschungsinstitut kommen bei der DFG
sind zwar alle Ideen willkommen aber man
ist beim Geld verteilen dann doch etwas
vorsichtiger und das gilt natürlich auch
für die anderen drittmittelanbieter
ein weiteres Hindernis für wirklich
bahnbrechende Forschung ist wohl auch
die internationale Konkurrenz unter
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern zählt vor allem
Geschwindigkeit ins Geschichtsbuch
kommen immer nur die ersten jeder kennt
Charles Darwin niemand kennt Alfred
Wallace und das bedeutet dass man
natürlich auch schaut dass man sobald
man einige Ergebnisse zusammen hat die
auch direkt publiziert man kann etwas
von dir sagen man schaut auf die
kleinste publizierbare Einheit der
Konkurrenzdruck verhindert also dass
einzelne Forschungsartikel unerwartete
bahnbrechen Erkenntnisse kundtun weil
jedes bisschen an neuer Erkenntnis
sofort veröffentlicht werden muss auch
der Ideenaustausch zwischen den
Fachbereichen ist unter diesem
Konkurrenzdruck schwierig solche
interdisziplinären Projekte dauern
schlicht sehr lange dr Schmidtmann hat
uns erzählt dass die antragstellenden
schon ein bis zwei Jahre einplanen in
denen sich die Beteiligten gegenseitig
nur auf den jeweiligen Stand der
Forschung bringen die eigentliche
Forschung kommt erst danach man kann
heute also nicht mehr jahrzehntelang an
einer Veröffentlichung arbeiten sich mit
den Kollegen aus dem weiteren Umfeld
austauschen und dann ein großes
Lebenswerk herausgeben dass
Kreationisten vom Glauben abfallen lässt
dafür haben wir heutzutage keine Zeit
mehr der anderen Seite ist die
Wissenschaft in Deutschland zumindest
grundsätzlich so eingerichtet dass
mutige und innovative Forschungsprojekte
jenseits des Mainstreams eine Chance
bekommen
okay aber was heißt das jetzt alles wir
erleben immer seltener Sprünge in
Forschung und Entwicklung das sehen wir
in verschiedenen Daten hier übrigens
auch zum Beispiel die Patente die jedes
Jahr angemeldet werden es könnte in der
Natur des Wissens liegen das ist immer
schwieriger wird neue Erkenntnisse zu
gewinnen aber das Gespräch mit der DFG
hat uns gezeigt dass es auch viele
systemische Zwänge in der Wissenschaft
gibt die dazu führen dass
kleinschrittige Forschung mit geringem
Risiko eher bevorzugt wird die
populistische Reaktion wäre jetzt mehr
Zeit und Geld für die Forschung zu
fordern insbesondere für die
Universitäten wo Professoren und
Professorinnen recht frei mit ihren
Forschungsbudgets umgehen können aber so
einfach ist es dann doch wieder nicht
denn wegen der vielen Faktoren die hier
eine Rolle spielen bleibt die Frage ob
die Ressourcen dann wirklich
gewinnbringend eingesetzt würden was
denkt ihr über das Thema mich wird das
sehr interessieren schreibt gerne mal
unten in die Kommentare und lasst uns
dort diskutieren aber am Ende bleibt
jetzt doch die Frage ist die
Wissenschaft denn nun am Ende ich glaube
dass der menschliche Geist wenn er an
Grenzen ankommt dann er versucht diese
Lust zu knacken und diese Hürde zu
überwinden und wieder neue Ansätze zu
finden also ich glaube dass das
Wissenschaft spannend macht das wird nie
aufhören und die Anzahl der Fragen die
man untersuchen kann die wird auch nicht
leben
in diesem Sinne bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric